[Music]
if you've been to disneyland you may
feel like you've seen parts of this
castle before but you're not dreaming
sleeping beauty this fairytale castle is
real
[Music]
the neuschwanstein castle was
commissioned by king ludwig ii of
bavaria in 1869.
he wanted the castle to resemble earlier
german palaces but the result is a
combination of styles and influences
ranging from the romanesque to gothic
his castle may look familiar it's the
inspiration behind sleeping beauty's
castle at disneyland
king ludwig ii was adored by the people
he was more commonly known as the fairy
tale king for his love of escaping
reality and his responsibilities as king
with music plays and fairy tale stories
however king ludwig did not get his
fairy tale ending
he was declared insane in 1886 and
removed his king by his cabinet
a few days later he died under
mysterious circumstances
he only had a chance to live in the
unfinished castle for six months before
his death
regardless this castle has inspired the
imagination of countless generations